c'est une scène qui est tristement
familière désormais dans la bande de
gaza le matin le voisinage vient et des
couvre les dommages causés par les
bombardements au cours de la nuit ici
cinq familles habitaient dans un édifice
une sixième était venu se réfugier du
nord de la bande de gaza france en se
mettant à l'abri des combats à 7h30
selon les voisins puis on a parlé
le patriarche de toutes ces familles a
reçu un appel des forces armées
israéliennes ordonnant la famille de
quitter la maison
on les a prévenus qu'on allait bombarder
dans une quinzaine de minutes alors tout
le monde s'est précipité ramasser tous
deux fait personnelle dans la mesure du
possible effet sauvé vous voyez ce matin
ça fume encore les secours d'urgence
sont finalement venus pour tenter
d'éteindre le feu mais ils sont débordés
ils ont beaucoup de ce genre d'
incendies a tenté d'éteindre la
population qui avait tout autour ne se
sent en sécurité nulle part à
bouabdallah le voisin qui habite la
maison juste à côté nous a dit avoir
finalement fui avec sa femme ils se sont
réfugiés dans la famille élargie ils
sont très nombreux à l'intérieur de la
maison et ne crois pas qu'il puisse y
rester très longtemps
selon les nations unies les centres
d'hébergement temporaires qui ont été
mises à la disposition de la population
des écoles dit
j'ai parlé programme des nations unies
ici déborde on on en est pardon à plus
de cent mille personnes qui ont trouvé
refuge dans ces écoles mais elles ne
font pas nécessairement à l'abri hier
l'unrwa l'agencé pour les réfugiés
palestiniens ici dans la bande de gaza
annoncé qu'une de ses écoles avaient été
la cible à quelques reprises de tirs de
mortiers vraisemblablement de la part
des forces armées israéliennes
l'houdinois demande l'ouverture d'une
enquête immédiate ici marie-eve bédard
radio-canada gaza